[موسيقى]
على المحك تبدو العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده في نوفمبر الماضي اتفق
الرئيساني الامريكي جو بايدن والصيني بعد
لقاء عندما 3 ساعات في جزيره بالي
الاندونيسيه عشيه قمه العشرين على اداره
التنافس بين بلديهما لكن تساؤلات رافقت
هذا الطموح فعلى الارض ثمه ماذا يشجع على
ذلك لم تمر الا اسابيع وعلى وقع حادثه
تحليق منتظم مراقبه صيني فوق الولايات
المتحده حتى تصاعد التوتر بين واشنطن
وبيجين ارجع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيز
زياره كانت مقرره الى الصين لاكمال ما
بداه بيضا وشي في بالي حادث المنطاد لم
يكن ليتجاوز حقيقه اجراءات يتخذها البلدان
في سياق صراع لبوازين القوه وبسط النفود
والانتشار والامن والتجاره وابرز مسارحه
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
تايوان تبقى ابرز مسرح للتوتر لاكثر من
مره مناوره عسكريه صينيه حول الجزيره
وتحليق للطائره الحربيه في اجواء بحر
اليابان وبحر الصين الشرقي بل وحديث
استخبارتي امريكي عن اوامر من الرئيس
الصيني لجيشه بالاستعداد لغزو تايوان
بحلول عام 2027 توتر بدت مؤشرته فيما يقدم
عليه البلدان بعيدا عن التصريحات
الدبلوماسيه من خطوات واشنطن برسائلها الى
بيجين توقيعها في الفلبين صفقه لبناء اربع
قواعد عسكريه امريكيه جديده هي تريد بهذا
الحضور تعزيز قوس انتشارها العسكري حول
الصين فالفلبين هي الاقرب جغرافيا الى
تايوان بمسافه تقدر بنحو 1200 كم اليابان
بدورها تستضيف ما يزيد عن 50 الف جنديا
امريكي واعلنت في تغير اللافت عن عقيده
عسكريه جديده لاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بسبب تنام تهديدات الصين وروسيا
وفي نفس القوس تعتبر كوريا الجنوبيه ثالثه
اكبر مستضيف للقوات الامريكيه بعد اليابان
والمانيا
واضافه لساحات المواجهه مجالات اصطدام لا
تنافس باتت واشنطن تحاول التضييق فيها على
بيجيل فقد اتفقت اليابان وهولندا مع
الولايات المتحده على البدء في تقييد
الصادره معدات تصنيع الرقائق المتقدمه
واشباه الموصلات الى الصين التي تحتاجها
والانضمام الى جهود اداره بايدن لابطاء
تطور العسكري الصيني كما تدرس اداره بيضا
قطع جميع معاملات شركات التكنولوجيا
والاتصالات الامريكيه مع عملاق الاتصالات
الصيني هواوي وحضر جميع مبيعات الشركه في
ضوء مخاوف من صلاتها مع الدوائر العسكريه
والاستخباراتيه في الصين
[موسيقى]